dude it is unreal that stuff is actually
so true though like I will watch
something so much more if there's a guy
jumping through a Minecraft maze
the fact that like podcast Clips are so
boring now that you have to have a
[__] Subway Surfer thing at the
bottom just otherwise I can't watch it
yeah it's kind of weird yeah it's 15
seconds of my life but I need something
else to entertain me at the same time
wouldn't that become like a meta for
like two dogs I don't know but I did um
it was weird I did a video and someone
re-uploaded the entire thing to tick
tock which I don't care about [__] it
yeah reviews but they put rocket League
highlights below it
and it got 20 million views on Tick Tock
Jesus more than a girl on YouTube it was
just rocket League Clips below that's so
weird that's a [__] scam I I I saw I
saw this uh I saw this one like YouTube
short and it was just like a random
podcast clip or something that I didn't
really give a [__] about uh but what was
so distracting uh was there was this
like mobile game being played at the
bottom where you had to like collect
coins or something Subway Surfer yeah it
was a Subway Surfer it was like the
shittest player of all time he kept
missing every [__] Gem and I was like
that's how you got you engaged I was
like [__] again and I went to like
the commas and everyone was just like I
cannot stop like I cannot not notice how
[__] this person is at the game that
worked he turned a boring ass video into
a banger
where is it like where does it end
though like where's that stop how many
layers are they gonna get to but she's
gonna be like everything like Bells
going off the whole time I don't it's so
weird because whenever whenever I see
like that video where I was just like a
podcast or a clip by itself just isn't
enough anymore we need something to like
distract the brain yeah that's like how
they had had to add flashy subtitles to
everything which slowly become Japanese
TV yeah which means flashy subtitles you
mean well before when you had a clipster
podcast they wouldn't [__] subtitle
every goddamn word they say yeah but now
it's like every single every word
there's like little icons that pop up
there's like Concepts that's literally
what we do yeah yeah we do that secrets
on how to get views right yeah I feel
like this one we're just kind of like
hacking the brain well yeah because like
it like there's a standard for subtitles
already built yeah it's actually like
the most easy to read and legible yeah
yeah and obviously YouTube just throws
it out the window because you're like
well that's not [__] fast enough
do one word at a time pop up blue
animation go I find it interesting
because I know Mr Beast uses different
subtitles for tick tock as he does on
YouTube it's like different energies or
different platform like Tick Tock kind
of rejects the hybrid hyper-produced
like way that YouTube shorts work yeah
they're very much like condensed
original YouTube video I say original
yeah um but like
actual trying to tell some story or
whatever yeah and it's a little bit more
manufactured it's a little bit more of
like a set narrative set thing whereas
Tick Tock is meant to be more organic
it's people do it in each other it's
people talking to a camera you don't
really see that as much on YouTube
shorts but to literally to the level of
like psychologically changing the text
just so it comes off with a diff like
trying less hard That's like [__]
nuts because it it obviously makes a big
difference otherwise you wouldn't do it
yeah right yeah this is this is the new
age oh add Analyze This Tick Tock video
why is the subtitle this color but
genuinely it's cool yeah we're getting
to that point where everyone is making
micro adjustments to try and find the
perfect thing to hack your brain yeah
yeah especially on YouTube shorts
because everyone's making the same video
like everyone's just doing the same like
just screaming at you a lot of it's fake
a lot of it's just complete just garbage
but it just hooks you even if you I I
watch a YouTube show all the way through
I'm like I hated that why did I watch
yeah that was awful but I gave him watch
time you also get recommended like
YouTube shorts that have like no views
and it's just like a kid oh yeah yeah
like this is my wall because it's like
zero all the time why are you
recommending this [__] to me I guess
I've got to give everyone a chance right
yeah it's weird because I feel like
that's that's the algorithm trying to do
something but like normally you can tell
within I feel like with like YouTube
sorry why am I the [__] test dummy
for people I know I feel like I feel
like everyone's the test dummy I mean
videos have zero views at one point
right that's true but uh yeah I I feel
like you can tell when a video is not
like I I can like subconsciously tell
within like I say like point five
seconds oh yeah when like a video is
being recommended to me that has no
views at all yeah yeah yeah you can just
tell it's just the tick tock other I'm
just going to be like I know you liked
all these videos but what about this
Samantha left field yeah something
completely different have you been
recommended a lot of like just out of
context like scenes from movies and TV
shows yeah
like every Family Guy episode every
South Park episode I think I've
rewatched the entire John work Trilogy
through Clips out of order
yeah the amount of times
are clips of like Theo Von just saying
something stupid just because like
they'll just send me the same one every
time yeah I think I've seen I've never
seen peaky blinders but I feel like I
could recite basically every major thing
that's happened yeah I feel like I could
perfectly replicate a Joe Rogan episode
just based off weird [__] Clips with
his guests where they go like in the
Amazon forest there is a tribe the
perishless yeah it's it's the spiritual
energy of the river it actually makes
them Giga charge and it's just like what
am I what am I listening to have you
seen the the the Deep fake slash AI
Rogan Clips where they are fully talking
and the guest is fully talking their
mouths are fully moving it sounds
identical to him but they're advertising
some product yeah [__] fake oh
they're the when they were trying to
scam people to buy stuff yeah yeah well
it's just yeah it's fully fake yeah just
like trying oh it's crazy I like the
advertising this like
and obviously they do usually advertise
like supplements or some sort of thing
but like completely fake ones yeah it's
kind of like fake ads yeah I watched Joe
Rogan explaining Bionicle and that was
good but knowing that it could be used
for
knowing that it could be used for the
various reasons anymore no no it was
like him explaining Bionicles to Jordan
Peterson or something and it was really
funny because I just thought that they
were going at Deep In Depth into
Bionicle law and I just for some reason
I found that funny I guess they're like
he's poked us along right like so
[__] they've got to go down some
[__] rabbit holes of course yeah look
I I think I when I used to mow Lawns uh
my first job out of school I would
listen podcasts all the time I
definitely I think I listen to
surely at some point I listen to Joe
Rogan one but yeah like yeah yeah I mean
like I feel like his Clips are
inescapable especially I don't know why
it's specifically his Clips whenever
there's some kind of question outrageous
guests no it's it's one is like it's
always some kind of [__] conspiracy
going on like the pyramids man like
there's no tools that they could have
had to build them there and did you know
if you measure the base
this is the pyramids it's the actual
circumference of the earth
to within like micro percent degree well
my favorite one is always like so
there's always been writings about the
ancient city of Atlantis that was lost
through time and uh every every every
civilization talked about this and it
disappeared all at the same time even
though there's no no kind of like
evidence or whatever yeah like how many
how many conspiracy theories can we go
through that one's interesting
is interesting because
well it's like
Sahara
no no
yeah you know lots of tropical water all
that sort of stuff just has also slowly
been eroded and buried by the way all
the water go you'd never be able to
you'd never evaporation bro where'd all
the water go that's like was in nature
like there used to be like Australia was
underwater or something but no I don't
know I'm just saying it was like I don't
like have they checked all the sand
have they gone through with a metal
detector and seen if they found Atlantis
I don't know man you know my favorite
conspiracy theory Australia isn't real
no yes we were discussing this I got an
internet fights with uh the kid that
kept saying that he's so funny
no he just like he just says that when
you fly to Australia you're actually
getting drugged and dropped off in New
Zealand
and it's just funny when you actually
are and I mean we might not actually be
in Australia I actually had to think
about it for a second we are in
Australia yeah I'm not so overseas right
I love how I love how there's The
Narrative of like oh yeah this giant
island continent is not real New Zealand
is definitely real yeah we're all actors
yeah
so so did you make a video like calling
him out well these are back in my
reaction days this was like six years
ago right yeah a little beef yeah no he
just because he was just chatting so
much dumb [__] I was just going through
all these videos he was just trying to
bait for attention he was just making
all these videos just waffling on about
all sorts of random [__] I think he
still does this day and honestly
hopefully he's doing all right
um but you see people every now and then
just pick back up on it like I think
yeah there's been a few channels that
have made full dedicated videos to him
even in recent times because he just
pops up on Tick Tock just yeah chatting
some [__]
if anyone just talks a lot of [__]
you'll eventually get noticed say
something controversial have an extreme
opinion and share it with as many people
as possible that's how you make money
that's true was he meming or was he like
I he's today yeah I think he's just very
deadly
one commit to a character that hard yeah
it's it's like I don't know I I would
think out of context that flat earthers
are a meme but obviously they're like a
real thing right yeah where are they
[Music]
Mercy
the whole thing yeah
yeah no I I hope he was meme yeah
sometimes you don't know it's like is
this guy a character or is he actually
just crazy I can never tell with the
internet anymore from the flat earthers
there's like some intelligent Flat Earth
that's the thing right that's the thing
proved they kept accidentally proving
that the Earth was round but they were
like intelligent enough to be able to
set up all these experiments to prove
that the Earth was was round yeah it was
funny it's yeah it's I have no smart
people can be dumb yes definitely yeah
very much so that's why we watch anime
yeah yeah yeah do we have a recommend uh
another what the starter anime were I
feel like we got on I mean do you want
you want superpowers do you want fights
I love a good like
someone described Attack on Titan to me
I think they were saying like Game of
Thrones in a way in the sense of like
everyone everyone says is it really oh
because I guess like the scope of things
I'm not really sure like the actual
correlation but I guess maybe it's very
political yeah oh yeah I suppose that
part yeah that's actually very true so I
love like a good story in that regard
okay good I love Goodwill building okay
I love that [__] what about like a
Trigon stampede
you reckon that'd be a good starter or
probably not starter anime uh I'd sound
under but it's 140 episodes but it is
good yes
slowly get through but it is good if you
some want something that hits fast and
it's just very very easy to get through
uh one punch man oh one punch oh yeah
that's so good that is okay okay it's
basically about a superhero who trains
so [__] hard where he can kill
everything with one I think I've played
a Roblox game
okay is it always that you should watch
the subtitle version or should is there
sometimes that you think you should
watch them sometimes sometimes the dubs
are actually better than the Japanese
version yeah okay interesting because I
feel like it's a
you know a while back there was a lot of
shabs so a lot of English dub versions
which just weren't that great okay yeah
but there are a lot that are pretty
decent and I think we've gotten to this
point now where no one [__] cares and
just watch whatever works for you yeah
yeah if if you want to watch a show that
has like I think like a better like it's
better experience in English uh bachano
is uh incredible it's kind of like a
Quentin Tarantino movie interesting uh
you might also like Finland Saga
because I think there was something
interesting about subtitles I found I
was actually had to pay way more
attention to what I was watching yeah
you said it just like oh my God forbid
yeah the subway surf for [__]
[__] the bottom it's the same thing
as when you're sitting there watching a
show and you're like oh I've got Twitter
alert yeah you can't do that you have to
you have to actually be home you should
prop up Subway Surfer under your TV I I
sort of tick tock of someone who set up
their whole house it was like two TVs
above each other just to obviously make
fun of people like yeah it's just
someone doing like a presentation and
then they were like wait hold on and
then they held up Subway Surfer and
carried
[Music]
oh we're [__] doomeday we need to do
that with anime just have a full season
of [__] Attack on Titan except it's
just cropped and just like the holiday
stuff is just Subway Surfers we are
doomed as a people bro
you have some new anime that you can
watch as well yes yeah well when the
World's End you can always hit it up
you'd be like what's the next what's the
direction oh I will I will I mean it
sounds like I'm gonna have a little bit
to get through yeah do you travel do you
travel often last year I definitely did
uh pretty much lived in England for like
three months I'm so sorry
hey I love it I love it every Aussie
love English I wouldn't want to maybe
live there forever but yeah London's fun
yeah no London was really cool
um I'd never been to Europe or like oh
wow anywhere with like really old
buildings before you know whoa yeah I
was like [__] this is sick I also
just yeah I don't know just very
different energy I kind of like the cold
as well so it was a really cold when I
first went there
um I was doing content there which was
great yeah not for myself but it's nice
to get to travel and do content but also
have like off days where you can kind of
like get to do fun stuff oh yeah in a
place with a purpose and I really enjoy
that especially because it was like we
got locked down here for like two years
couldn't travel yeah yeah yeah I hope
the lockdown here was like not to make
it seem like it's the end of the world
it's a good place to be but um you know
when we could travel again it was yeah I
did a lot of it I did a lot of it yeah
yeah
um would you ever think about coming to
Japan I've been there once really been
there once yes I've been there once and
I went straight to naseco and
snowboarded for like five days
I know uh obviously you guys have a lot
of experience in Japan and I'm like I've
been there but I have not experienced
the culture I think I landed in Tokyo
went to the airport hotel and then went
straight to like naseca or something
dude this this Mexico in the on season
is just Australia it was maybe I was
just speaking like in an Aussie accent
in English to me very helpful but I'm
not getting any cultural experience here
or when you come to Tokyo hit us up oh I
would love to yeah I know pretty much
everyone I'm friends with right now is
like it's even separate friend groups is
like yeah I was thinking about Japan
this year yeah about Japan this year I'd
love to I mean I'm we're also down to
going to nisaco yeah as well I
definitely think I got to get back there
that was the best
we had an episode where we talked about
who we think the worst tourists are in
the world and Joey's like Aussies when
they go skiing
but I don't ski I snowboarded
we don't like them
I promise